JULIA PEIPERL: When
I got to Princeton,
I didn't know that
I wanted to do
theater design at all, because
I was interested in everything.
This is the set for
"Annie & Rose," which
is a current music
theater thesis
that I designed the set for.
It was a nice way to ease
my way into set design,
because this was very inventive.
Like what can we use this for?
And well, we don't
want to have a table,
so let's make it so that you
put a plank over two chairs,
and that becomes a table.
So it was really fun for me.
I really like that
kind of set design
where everything transforms.
And it's been fun to
get to work on that.
The nice thing about
Princeton is that there's
all these tiers of theater.
There's the thesis
department theater,
which is what I'm doing now.
And there's student theater.
I got the opportunity to do a
thesis show last year, which
was "Hero," which was this
crazy, high-flying aerial dance
piece.
And all of a sudden,
I was working
with a professional set designer
and a professional music
director.
And I feel comfortable
working in that community.
And it has helped me to build
up a skill set in that way.
So I took last semester a class
called advanced theater design.
And this class
really does throw you
right into the process
of designing a show.
So the big difference
between the shows
I've designed this
year, "Elektra,"
which I costume designed,
and "Annie & Rose," which
I set designed, and "Hero"
last year, for these shows,
I was made to do the
work that goes behind it.
All of this research, and all of
this planning, and all of these
sketches, and trying
stuff, and throwing it out
and meeting with the director.
And it was a really
full process.
And there were three
of us in the class.
We got guidance every
step of the way.
I came to Princeton for
a liberal arts education,
which I'm getting.
But at the same
time, I'm getting
to do real design in a real
context with real background.
So having these certificates,
I think, is giving me
the best of both worlds.